this week's videos are sponsored by
expressvpn more on them after the
reaction people citizens of the reject
Nation we are back for Scott Pilgrim
takes off episode dose today John how
are you I am terrific Gregory how are
you I am
swdic ladies and gentlemen if you did
not catch a reaction to episode one I
think it's on the channel otherwise we
are doomed with that in mind please go
ahead subscribe click that notification
Bell to get notified when our reaction
for episode thr is up here on the
channel and and as always rock out to
that like button that would be very much
appreciated big thank you to prepper for
helping us edit down these highlights
full length R watch along sync up with
your own copy of Scott Pilgrim takes off
that is available for our super sexy
rejects that is over at our patreon page
thank you to all who have joined already
us to cover several things exclusively
with reaction highlights and watch
alongs included John are you ready to
continue with sex the bomb dude insert
that coin let's
go
[Music]
won I won false sense of hope that means
you and I are free to get back together
right those are the rules of the league
that's how love works pathetic did
anyone get that fight on video you guys
leaving is there an after
party what's going on
oh
uh-oh where did everybody go
is the show over there was no show the
Bas player was punched to
death Dad yes those are the words I said
who's that voice
[Music]
yeah oh she dying her hair oh yeah she
must have to all the time or have we
gone back A League of Their Own there's
no crying in video
games the girl of of or from Scott's
dreams well how are you is this his
funeral this is his
funeral this is
awesome I can't believe he's
[Laughter]
gone he was always taking on High level
enemies yeah but he always won nobody
wins forever the house
does true
casinos I'm going to sit next to someone
else dude you could play Scott you know
on some slots I guess now I'll never
know if we sucked which is kind of nice
just wish it were under different
circumstances Missy pal is she just a
coin yeah two coins placed where the
eyes would be for the boat
[Music]
man a she's got his jacket Xavier school
for grieving youngsters what are you
doing here you killed SC Pilgrim oh did
she say killed this this is Juicy I
don't know if that's fair it'd be fun to
go to a funeral like this yes this has
got to be the most dramatic funeral I've
ever been to it doesn't get more
dramatic or does it oh I think it
does Ramona inverted the colors in her
hair right is Gideon showing up oh oh I
bet he
is like ninja
Rozi Envy Adams oh oh snap the big
one oh my god wow it's like the emperor
shown up
Empress
Showtime no o la la and I call Queen
mommy seriously the coolest Funeral Ever
Jesus grief ninjas I love the way that
ninjas are be the paparazzi is being
portrayed yeah and Adams is amazing
she's the Le of my favorite band of all
time Bri I thought we were your favorite
band well they're my favorite real band
sex B bombs my favorite band that isn't
real ouch a Scott Scott deserve better
as you all know I briefly dated Scott
Pilgrim in my pre- celebrity life we
didn't all
know
[Laughter]
I thought I'd sing a song in his
memory Black Sheep Lady Gaga thing going
on
[Music]
yeah Scott dated her crazy right can you
imagine having an ex who became a huge
celebrity after you broke up oh she
knows we the
me
you know what's funny her voice sounds
like the lead singer of metric who's the
band that did the song for the movie who
Brie Larson sang the track for so if
they brought the singer metric to do
this I think it' be a really funny Twist
on that
screaming hilarious yes yes I'm glad
that joke
landed there he
is
it's like a
howler oh they're being activated why
though he's
dead you all need to go and try and woo
Ramona
again
gfred dear evil X all seven of you are
cordially invited to a very special
evening
whoa did I just get invited to my own
lirer is Scott putting this together or
Ramona or something are they writing
Scott Pilgrim off the show yes Scott
Pilgrim takes off from the series never
to be heard from again I'm sorry
Scott he just all right I'm Miss Le I am
a I'm a huge fan tell me something I
don't know it's great to hear that voice
again Chris
Hemsworth secret
[Laughter]
lir
yeah Johnny Bravo's tough cousin Todd
Lucas maybe you should stick to the
rivers and the lakes that you're used to
let the pros do the pro things vegans
have perfect photographic memories that
could memorize an entire script just
like that yep yep yep I hear the snap
with him yeah it's called being in the
moment is that why half your lines in
your last movie were let's
party drink sir let's
party this is appropriate it's fun
seeing them actually all interact with
each other why'd you bring us here
Gideon I didn't the person behind this
event remains a mystery he didn't invite
them who invited the
robot no one did
what for it is I who did the invied
Matthew Pat he was entitled the robots
with us the first one we ever built we
call him robot 01 we gendered him too
male this party was
curing no plus one I thought it was like
a joke about intimate toys for a moment
I brought you all here because I've
realized there's a fiddle flaw in our
league a failure of leadership are you
questioning my methods first one is
taking this Uprising I Matthew tell
defeated Ramona's new boyfriend and got
nothing for it no if we win we don't get
Ramona I flawlessly defeated her
precious little Scott and she still
turned me down oh gasp gasp
gasp you really think i' just hand the
league over no I think I'll fight you
for it let's go I own two record labels
a movie studio 14 animal shelters and
this league you're a DE plus theater
student with delusional Broadway dreams
you're not worth my time burn somebody's
scared what did you just say she said it
sounds like sounds like somebody's
scared if you win you can take it all if
you lose which you will I take your life
I accept those terms what do you stand
to benefit from that 90 cents
apparently
what a fun crossover of sorts G Graves
versus Matthew Batel
[Music]
fighto oh
great that's an excellent shot yeah come
on
girls
niceoo
oh cool with the screen cracking
effect
wo got you now I feel like I'm watching
Powerpuff curls we went from like red
Tron into Powerpuff
curls oh I'm just getting started how do
you defeat
[Music]
him out making moves on the
court it's a
fireball oh damn it's like that NBA Jam
game from back in the day when the ball
would go on fire
yeah time to take this fight to the next
level
yeso
what are the rules on the ghost
Sidekicks can they
regenerate
whoa create stuff out of matter or
energy or light come on
out surprise attack surprise
attack oh that's neat the speed of the
swords that makes it look like a
shield oh let's
go wa oh jeez it's all his successes
his what's on the Vault I don't know the
body is scotten
yes o
damn
nice got to have a fight in the
[Music]
rain ooh
Trident this is pretty epic damn yeah
and very creative with the powers and
stuff you're
mine
[Music]
damn ooh tension to detail on this as
the blades in the tri removing and he's
moving in his formation it's
over finish it
I got to stop eating meat and milk and
eggs if I could uh just have your
signature right here Mr Graves what's
this the result of this fight is legally
binding everything of yours now belongs
to Mr Patel is that Cal Pen's voice yeah
yeah great
catch fine how does that paper sustain
during this
water do it put me out of my misery it's
one of those Market tablets no I want to
put you into your
misery yeah living your worst life oh
the downward rainfall this is my league
now I'm the main character what a
switcher yeah
Tod
twin other twin that's two
roxan that's literally what I was going
to say
Roxy you have something the other X's
don't you should join me we could be a
league of two I don't need a league to
get a girl have a nice life loser you
proba how she's draped like an actual
ninja yeah and the mask kind of looks
like that my hero Academia girl yeah oh
the vampire girl
yeah cat
Pilgrim yeah oh that's such a cool
choice the predominantly blue with a
little bit of Hope at the bottom and
then when she's more a beat it's like
you know fun and colorful but with that
Melancholy at the bottom
Sparks
uhhuh an interesting grief of a
situation to be able I like the like one
plus one two three yeah times three six
it's clever damn great miracle device
yeah and the way they do lens flaring is
beautiful too with these like layered
opaques or transparents I should
say
Scott does she bring him back to
life he's
alive damn it Emily Haynes and metri Dam
you called it John it was Emily Haynes
and
Calen I have won the
episode that's funny because Brie Larson
like they famously
metric did the Black Sheep song uh you
know hello again friend of a friend uh
and then they had Brie sing it for the
movie because she is a singer and then
they eventually released on the deluxe
edition and and stuff they released the
Brie version which to me is like kind of
the definitive version of that song So
to have Emily Haynes do the the vocal
here is is I think really fun and
funny you know what I've gotten from you
talking about this what how funny you
think it is I it's Charming to me it's
it's okay maybe not fun maybe I'll go
John I got to tear you down because I I
don't have any way to really contribute
to this I did not know this fact my
method is to punch down yes of course
that's called an inferiority complex all
right learn to weaponize it at any given
moment God oh you know that's probably
good advice League made that's good
advice for me I would definitely fit in
with the leak I was going to say I'm
trying to say this would be good yeah
big thanks to expressvpn for sponsoring
this video a real game changer I've been
using for years that's right years so
whenever they want to work with us it's
an instant yes you've likely heard about
expressvpn for online privacy and
security but there's more to it than
that however there was a very real
incident recently with Spectrum Shing
down my internet and contacting me due
to a suspecting hacking attempt and
funny enough I realized I hadn't
actually activated my expressvpn on my
new laptop that I got a couple of months
ago so I was paying the consequences
Haven faced a serious hacking issue on
YouTube a couple years ago that made
expressvpn my go-to for both security
and freedom I mean it and yes what you
heard is true believe me this channel
knows you can use expressvpn to watch
movies and shows on Netflix that are not
available in your country this means
accessing a vast rate of content of over
a 100 countries like a global Cinema of
your fingertips it's super easy open
expressvpn switch locations refresh the
browser and there you have it whether
it's K dramas on South Korean Netflix
Hulu BBC I player YouTube or more
expressvpn has you covered and it's
incredibly fast ensuring no buffering or
lack for smooth HD streaming it's
versatile too working on not just
computers but phones media consoles
Smart TVs and more this means you can
enjoy your favorite shows on anywhere
any screen protect and elevate your
internet experience so if you want to
get access to hundreds of new shows use
my link expressvpn.com Rejects and you
can get an extra 3 months of expressvpn
for free that's
expressvpn.com rejects so head to
expressvpn.com rejects to learn more
thank you again well I feel enriched and
and that's yeah we should definitely
support that you know what else we
should support is uh getting those fresh
drips at reation shop.com oh my God two
at once two at once I mean just get it
out of the way so that we can just
unfold and enjoy the Scott Pilgrim but
look at that snip snip look at this
Classic ticket shirt yeah you guys could
be so much more comfortable there at
home you know what why don't we just
shout out another thing just in G fuel
has been powering my whole day today so
uh I think if we shout out a fourth one
that way it's just it's something that
might be in the future that we could
potentially get status audio I love your
headphones uh please sponsor this
channel uh the wireless uh you know the
the the Bluetooth ones they sound
amazing especially for your music fan
and uh you know these are called ad
blocks we're taking care of all them
right now uhhuh y
Chevrolet anyhow what do you think of
this episode of Scott Pilgrim I really
enjoyed it um it part of the the thing
when it comes to stakes in an episode
like this is you're fully aware that of
course Scott's not dead yes part of me
was kind of curious like would they just
kill him off because that might be an
interesting Direction what I like is the
deviation of like again I got to just
remind people don't know what the source
material is most people I imagine who
are watching this are primarily just
familiar with the movie I have to
imagine and
you watch that first episode that seems
to riff so much off of the movie like it
doesn't really deviate so much from that
first half or first 30 minutes or
whatever of of uh the film and then this
one takes a a very different direction
maybe it's close to the source material
uh Maybe not maybe it's just doing its
own thing I don't know it's an
interesting structure though to take our
main character off the map introduce a
new kind of set of rules for your world
which already doesn't really have a
rules other than you beat people in
video game like
scenarios and then to focus on all your
villains all the people you were going
to go up against and using our
familiarity of how Scott would just
encounter them one onone in situations
and then have them all congregate with
each other H and then get to kind of
know their personalities and know the
Menace of that and also do a flipper
where you take your first character your
first ex make him the dominant one to
lead when really he in many ways you
might view him as like one of the weaker
ones off of your association with the
film because of the fact that he was the
first one to go and here they
reestablished like the numbers go up so
like he's literally like the bottom and
then you also have Gideon who you
associate as the top dog the most
ruthless one the hardest one to defeat
and then you have him taken off of the
the the the leadership board here when
it comes to the league to focus it all
on that I think is a very fascinating
deviation with some really cool dark
visuals laced throughout it's like to
keep to do your focus on okay first
episode is Ramona and Scott not really
so much The Supporting Cast but they're
there and then the second episode is the
entire
villains with your first and last one
really put all your emphasis
there but I my the thing with it was and
and like what's interesting about it is
you know they release all them at once
Netflix usually designs are shows to be
binged and I imagine my opinion of this
might actually change during um the uh
after we're done with the show because I
like this one I did find myself going I
don't care as much though because I
don't I'm not invested in in these guys
to focus on them just yet like I'm
fascinated by it I like it I'm trying to
find ways to word it where it doesn't
sound like I dislike the episode uh it I
just found like I don't really I could I
could have used a little bit of a
balance but again most people binge this
show whereas you and I are the due to
the nature of our channel uh we will
watch an episode and talk about it you
know which I'm sure when you have a
different director per episode and a
different script per episode they want
each episode to be taken and not just
kind of like forgotten about in The
Ether of a binge watch yeah so there's
that pro and con to watching something
talking about it versus watching
everything all at
once uh however yeah there was this
there there was a thing where I was like
I'm really I'm I'm intrigued by this I'm
interested I I like the emotional
Association of uh challenging of The
Challenge on the audience to take a
completely different direction and focus
uh but they're I I F I find that you
know when you get the voice actors from
the films you're naturally there will be
an association from film to listening to
this a and somewhat of a
similar um uh illustration I mean that
just in the animated format like
illustrate portrayal there will be a
similar type of uh portrayal while
they're doing some differences I find
that the Dynamics of the villains are
more interesting when it is antagonist
versus Scott versus them all being
together so this was the most I actually
found myself doing a real comparison MH
in a way where I found it was the portra
like I like the world I like the setting
I thought the fight scene was great
there was so much I really really really
liked about it but overall I'd still
probably rate this episode as an
experience more like a 7.5 out of 10
whereas the last one was like a 9.5 out
of 10 for me yeah because I didn't find
the Dynamics as interesting as the setup
into this ultimately was leading me to
believe when we were watching them all
first interact yeah and get together
does that make sense what I'm trying to
say yeah absolutely because I don't want
it to miss I don't want it to be
misunderstood that I didn't like it
because I I did um but I did find myself
like the last time I was comparing away
but I found myself like I'm in love with
this this one I was like o I'm there's
something that's kind of missing for me
here and it is the uh it it's actually
making their personalities not as in
their personalities are actually not as
interesting together yeah when you think
they would be more
interesting yeah I think they got good
humor especially out of that I think the
the most endearing aspect is just kind
of the flourishes that they'll put on
the group responses in particular when
it's like a rapid fire of like they're
all chiming in and inevitably I think
it's Brandon Ralph is like always either
like a bit slower than everybody or he
goes gasp at one point uh it like those
little flourishes I thought were really
fun but I am a bit I really enjoyed the
episode but I am of two minds about how
it places because on the one hand
episodically I'm like oh this is kind of
a cool diversion from what I'm familiar
with based off the movie uh but also
this ALS this felt like an episode that
could have come later or something in
terms of just like how intense it is in
the other direction cuz the first
episode to kill off scott so early like
I think they should have done it like on
a third or fourth villain that's my
initial thought I'll wait I'll wait to
see on that because I I could see myself
agreeing with you part of me really
admires and and thinks is fun that they
that they subverted the expectation by
just having the first Showdown be the
the death of Scott just cuz also as an
icebreaker it's like okay well this
shows you actually how serious the
situation is that you know you crumbled
up and discarded moments ago um and I
think it's a fun hook you know for the
end of the first episode but yeah like
looking back at that the first episode
had this beautiful kind of short film
sort of quality where it is yeah it's
this more intimate more breathy thing
whereas this is doing more stuff it's
going more kinetic maybe than the last
one at least and so yeah yeah like the
funeral in and of
itself I'm going to hold off too much
rewriting again cuz we're only on
episode two but like the funeral could
in itself kind of be the setting of an
entire episode without having to cut
away to the x's and things like that um
and yeah like I really lik the
physicality I really like the World
building I really like the again the
subversion of the action of just of uh
Patel just like taking over you know um
but yeah it it doesn't have quite as
much of that endearing or just time to
soak in those little tiny details I did
really like like the whole thing of
Ramona uh flipping the color in her hair
uh which seemed like a very very
deliberate thing that they chose to
really experientially kind of put you in
the POV of which I thought was a nice I
thought her buttons were really nice on
that and then her in the bed just kind
of missing the moment and then and
segueing that into another I think again
solid Cliffhanger like oh he's out there
oh I'm kind of waiting on episode three
to know exactly how these first couple
feel almost because again it's it's
starting to feel like three episodes
will give you kind of your complete
setup maybe um and we'll kind of find
out in discovering the circumstances
with Scott sort of what the real Stakes
are in terms of this battle against the
evil xes and all that stuff um so yeah I
mean like I think it's still plenty rich
and like the animation like I I am
continually taken with and and pleased
by the animation simply because it
really really and I think that's like a
the credit of the studio name is the
first thing you see in the opening
credits but like it really feels like no
expense was spared this wasn't hampered
by like oh you know it's streaming we
got whatever it feels like art in the
tradition that seems to be waning right
now um and I'm glad glad glad for that
because again this gave us a whole new
palette of things to look at especially
at Gman the Gman headquarters building
and all that stuff and yeah plenty of
like really funny little nods and and
jokes and like you know press the secret
layer button to get to the penthouse
secret layer um so yeah like this was a
really fun one just maybe had less of
yeah those like quiet intimate intimate
just like Slice of Life moments that
made the first episode so striking in a
way that was so unexpected whereas this
is a little bit more expected well this
is more serious and a little bit more
Grim with some darker humor to the
characters to try to keep some of that
Personality yeah um yet I still feel
like it it somehow even even though it's
animated even though they do a lot more
technically on the surface with the
league yeah they're not it's it still
feels like a little bit diminished in
personality to me I feel like yeah
having them all together then causes you
to be like what is the collective like
what's the collective goal here that you
could all feel like you're winning at uh
and and I think that's that's probably
part of the the the fun and the charm
but having them all to together does
highlight that at least some of them are
kind of similar or yeah it just makes a
lot of sense to me that they will each
probably shine better when they are the
singular
antagonist obstacle Etc to Scott in this
moment you know and then the others are
in the back of my mind less they're all
right here you know at the same time
like I I feel I could hear someone
coming back and being like I cuz I was
really really into this episode s
significantly and it was kind of a
strange experience as that as in the
last like 10 minutes of it were I was
like oh am I um I'm becoming a bit
apathetic to the emotionality right now
it caught me part way I had like one of
those levs partway through the fight
where I was like oh this is like this
episode this is like what this episode
is mostly about which I was kind of
surprised by yeah but I'm like I don't
really care about the fight because I
don't really know what they're fighting
for really give a about what it is
they're fight I I don't they want Ramona
one way or another but but also like in
the power
structure other than yeah they want kind
of a rearrangement of that power
structure like this is kind of the first
we're getting of their Collective
Rapport yeah now you're watching like
seven people with a with one note yeah
yeah yeah and and so like it's interest
in in some senses I think this is a fun
and interesting way to get first Glimpse
at them however there are just ways in
which this version of it then kind of
yeah compels you to go like I might yeah
be that much more engaged by this if I
had a little greater sense for a couple
of the different Dynamics between them
or their specific Tendencies or whatever
because we mostly know um or a little
bit more of a buildup to them actually
congregating for the first time sure for
congre the first time for the audience
to witness yeah I like the whole thing
with the letters and the whole like who
assembled us here and I liked even that
like it's kind of right under your nose
you're like who's number one oh I guess
it would be number one on the
roster but that even while I enjoyed
that and thought it was charming and fun
could have been laced in a more gradual
way or or in a differently structured
episode yeah you could have made that
more of like what are these letters for
and who are they going to and why and
then and then get yeah get some kind of
yeah greater buildup to that but still
very creative and I'm still very much
invested in the show because like I said
it's it's it's two like it's not really
2third of everything that was on screen
there's like two-thirds of the emotional
there's onethird of the emotionality
that was missing for me you know that
that's probably the best way I'd say it
like three out of three on everything
else but two thirds of the emotionality
was kind of gone from like sered really
waiting for me towards the end in the
last in the last like 10 minutes yeah
yeah and that and that's the only um
it's more of a simple array of emotions
in this one because the fight and the
the power struggle takes up so much you
know and we're not really focusing on
the fact that they're like all hung up
on this girl with that stuff so yeah
it's just not quite as the first episode
just has so many like interesting
nuances that all kind of relied on the
fact that they weren't doing bombastic
action so yeah yeah like there's not
enough room it feels like in this
episode the Ramona beats and stuff and
even the funeral to some degree have
that but yeah it's like the those are
doing so much of the emotional lifting
that they're accounting probably for a
lot of that 2third yeah and then the
villain stuff is is fun and intriguing
and and you know enjoyable but yeah less
impactful at least in this immediate
moment cuz the last thing I want
honestly is for them to just do the
movie like that's the last thing I want
like that'd be a waste of time yeah um
so that's why I was like really into it
at first yeah and and it's it's funny
because the first episode that that
thing Edgar right said about like going
blind it's not exactly the movie in the
first episode I was like okay I I get
tonally how that true there is a lot
still familiar here whereas this episode
was was like okay yeah we're out we're
well out of movie territory certainly at
least structure like great yeah yeah and
I mean too like the again the way they
captured like the falling rain and just
like the convex path all that stuff yeah
visually very striking um yeah but yeah
but there's more to it than just cool
visuals there has to there always has to
be that for for me at least as a viewer
hund I have to know why I should care
about watching this this is more of a
yeah this episode did a lot more setup
type stuff because it's like you get
your setup for um uh what's her name
Clash demon head you get your setup for
her who will be some kind of a villain
then you get your set the Roxy girl
yes right
Roxy yeah yeah the lesbian one or
bisexual no no no no no no no who comes
to the funeral who used to date Scott
who's the lead singer of clash EnV Adams
Adams there you go uh yeah you get her
set up Scott Pilgrim fan you are you
can't remember mvy Adams all this
about Brie Lon in this B
em is credited in the intro and I'm like
is she in this episode did they just let
Emily Haynes do the whole thing but yes
Envy Adams I should not have forgotten
for a minute she did she did but I'm I'm
wondering if Brie Larson did the lines
for this one which I mean she probably
did but at the same time sure she had
the time on the day she recorded her but
part of me is like I mean you could just
let she didn't interact with anyone yeah
so I feel like you could let Bri Larson
do the rest of the episodes where she
probably will be interacting but I
almost feel like they just let Emily
Haynes do the whole thing here but
either way it's setting up uh uh Envy
Adams and that antagonistic presence
that she will surely bring and then it's
setting up don't call me the entire
array of evil exists it's when I develop
my drinking problem uh yeah sets up all
of your different antagonists and and
their odds with each other so yeah like
to me this was all mo more in service of
that and
I yeah I don't begrudge a second episode
doing that especially after the First
episodes spent so much time in the
feeling most people by this point of us
talking have already finished episode 4
this is true and I'm waiting to finish
episode three to see how these first two
complemented so I'm excited more more
more
all right well guys thank you so much
for being here Scott pgam takes off keep
a look off our reaction to episode three
um thank you again and
hey's guys there's only a few days left
in the month there's only so many days
left in the month so we got to shout out
two people today to make sure we're
hitting our count because there's a
certain amount who pledge every month
making our lives difficult it's true
where we must do two shout outs oh crap
in one video what is this a backto back
ad read oh I guess so in a way the short
the least well okay who do you want to
shout out Let's do let's pair up Lance
door and Andrew Hayes our tallest and
shortest patient is that what this is
rooted in no I don't know know how tall
Lance
is but uh I don't know I mean what it's
rooted in something silly for me but
also it's rooted in something genuine
and I'll go with the genuine first give
it a shot genuine shot here uh Lance
door and Andrew Hayes both bring a
general kind of lovely cheer and on
Lance's end you know I mean he's a
familyman he's a guy who's out here you
know doing a service to his community
very genu fighting fires and whatnot and
got to worry about and still here
nerding out with us and at least taking
some of the living that he makes by
risking his life I've never felt such
authenticity before he's uh get ready
man we're going deep today when Lance uh
came to visit me in the hospital oh my
God you put the real and real rejection
that's right that's right and uh I don't
know just the fact that you know you
probably have enough to where you got a
budget your life and you know you got
all this to worry about you still take a
piece of that pie and give it to our
cause I the fact that you who does way
more important work in this world than
at least someone like myself would take
that no I mean you're you're me you're
feeding all of us rejects fighting fires
is not the same as people need to be
entertained doing YouTube videos man I'm
no it's not anyone can fight a fire yeah
it's pretty simple you know fire wall
yeah not point it in the right direction
and you're good just find a nearby hose
and you're you're contributing civilian
uh-huh all you are is just a paid
civilian really yeah you're just where
you're the taxes yeah so really you
contributing is just the natural order
things because you're giving us our damn
tax money my money goes to your
Universal Health Care in Canada that's
right oh yeah then Andrew Hayes Andrew
you know say something sweet about him
would you my God you got nothing to say
it's all about Lance is such a boyish
charm on this guy and he has grown
subjective into such a man over time you
know he looks like the kind of guy I
would have wanted to know tangent call
he knows he gets shouted out being like
it's okay cuz once he sees these a tear
is sure lost his credit card he's
somebody else is fraudulently continuing
his pledge uh yeah but either way I mean
aware or not aware I still appreciate
you man you're a Craftsman you're a
creative guy all right I admire your
creative Spirit and the way in which uh
you have enriched our lives with your
generosity as well because much like
Lance I'm sure you got a bunch to worry
about I'm sure you're making your way in
this life trying to forge a career and
whatnot trying to use your skills and
interests it's a lot out there but
you're still here here with with us what
are you saying I'm I I feel such a
unique energy right now
as it's good it's good is it okay glad
you can make a solid assessment of your
shout out I it's good this is a good
shout out I'm doing I'm doing a good job
shouting them out right but Andrew if
you have forgotten and this is just like
an automatic payment I mean like thanks
but bummer but if you're still here
watching that means a lot because
especially in the formation of this
patreon you are one of the people who
has been here through like all the
random tears that have dissolved in into
you know the the rear view you know we
used to get on Google Hangouts with you
you know we used to chat and now I feel
like you know I'm missing that so uh you
know Skype in tell you what I'll I'll
bring it back and you can handle all
all yeah and the p man everyone's like I
got to get my hour in with John then uh
you know I'm like okay what what time
zone are you in luckily Andrew not too
far away so that helps I don't know
exactly what the time zone would be for
Lance probably not too crazy different
either so that helps um but yeah I don't
know my real motivation here was that I
wanted you guys to like team up somehow
because think of it you know it's like
Lance is the firefighter right he's the
big he's the buff you know he could be
the muscle and then Andrew can like you
know jump on his back right and he can
like Scout and he can use his like you
know sneakiness and lockpicking skill
like it would be a perfect pair for a
video game yeah totally right feel
because then you know you would do a lot
of your major gaml as Lance probably and
then Andrew would be there to like make
fun comments but then there are certain
missions where you have to detach Andrew
and let him like you know crawl through
a vent or a puzzle or you know fight
people that aren't good to be fought by
a tall guy you know like things like
that and then we can use your real life
nness you know the firefighting skills
and the locksmith skills and your Cinema
skills and your Cinema appreciation
between the two of you to create some
kind of amazingly revolutionary kind of
like first third person third person
shooter game that's that's that's who I
want you guys to be or like some kind of
6 and half minutes anyway guys thank you
for being here we love the both of you
and stay pledged no matter if you're
aware or not this is good peace this is
[Music]
good